sieben hawking der berühmte physiker der
welt hat die menschheit gewarnt
der kontakt zur aliens könnte schlimm
für uns enden
doch andere wissenschaftler sind
wiederum anderer meinung und laut nasa
wissenschaftler sind wir kurz davor
außerirdische zu finden
es ist eines der hauptziele der
weltraumagentur sollten wir lieber damit
aufhören weil wir ansonsten von aliens
angegriffen werden jetzt wirklich zum
seitenwechsel herzlich willkommen die
suche nach aliens wird immer weiter
intensiviert sei es hier im sonnensystem
oder lichtjahre entfernt auf exoplaneten
und in beiden richtungen werden wir
immer erfolgreicher auf enceladus dem
saturnmond könnte es tatsächlich leben
geben
es scheinen alle daten dafür zu sprechen
und nachdem die sonde cassini diese
datenbank durch flug von geysiren auf
dem saturn und gefunden hat wird jetzt
überlegt wie leben dort tatsächlich
gefunden werden könnte aber von solchen
engen geht natürlich keine gefahr aus
zumindest nicht wenn wir sie nicht mit
auf die erde bringen wochen warnt auch
vor der kontaktaufnahme mit aliens auf
exo planeten außerhalb unseres
sonnensystems er vergleicht die ms
kontakt mit der entdeckung amerikas die
urbevölkerung wurde dort nahezu
vernichtet und die europäer nahmen den
gesamten kontinent ein laut hawking
würde genau das auch mit einer spezies
passieren die uns einige milliarden
jahre voraus sein könnte wenn wir uns
unsere umständen nicht freundlich
gewinnt wären dann wären wir ein
leichtes ziel und und das hat jetzt
nicht mal hawking gesagt die europäer
die nach christoph kolumbus amerika
bietet damen waren der urbevölkerung
noch nicht mal feindlich gesinnt wie
nahm nur immer mehr lang bis sich die
indianer werten aber da war es zu spät
die europäer waren ihnen mit ihrer
waffentechnologie einfach haushoch
überlegen der astronom selbst schostag
widerspricht aber hawking er zwei gründe
an
bombel nichts zu befürchten haben wenn
es eine hochentwickelte spezies gebe
dann hätte die uns von längs durch
unsere vielen spuren die wir im weltall
durch raumsonden satelliten und
radiosignale hinterlassen haben entdeckt
und dann auch attackiert außerdem ist
die schostag sicher dass keine spezies
in der nähe unseres sonnensystems über
zwischen nutzen
verfügen würde um uns zu attackieren sie
bräuchten einzigartige waffen um uns aus
der schwerelosigkeit an zu können
allerdings ist es kein wunder dass tag
hier so vehement einen alien angriff aus
schließt er leidet das windprojekt die
abkürzung steht für search for
extraterrestrial intelligence immobilien
gerade hat die erste ergebnisse ihrer
breakthrough listen initiativ bekannt
gegeben
demnach gibt es für die elf interessante
außerirdische signal im universum die
jetzt näher untersucht werden sollen
zwar sei die wahrscheinlichkeit gering
dass es sich um ein original handelt
aber sie werden trotzdem als
vielversprechend bezeichnet und auch bei
der suche nach exoplaneten kommen wir
immer weiter voran
jetzt wurde die atmosphäre eines
exoplaneten er untersucht die
zusammensetzung kann nämlich hier von
der erde aus analysiert werden wenn der
planet an seinem zentralgestirn vorbei
zidan fällt licht durch die atmosphäre
und daran wie sich das sternenlicht in
so einem fall verändert kann die
atmosphäre wer genau untersucht werden
ist also nicht unwahrscheinlich dass wir
schon bald einen exoplaneten mit leben
finden werden 3000 haben wir bereits in
den letzten jahren entdeckt und wenn
erst das james webb weltraumteleskop das
nachfüllen gestartet worden ist wird
diese zahl explodieren
dass sie das kugl viel genauer als alles
was wir bisher als beobachtungs
instrument zur verfügung hatten
aber was passiert dann wenn wir sie
gefunden haben wenn wir vielleicht
kontakt aufnehmen wenn sie in worb
antrieb bereits erfunden haben und in
ein paar wochen hin sein werden ich
finde dass sich beide wissenschaftler zu
einfach machen es muss ja kein angriff
seien sie könnten ja erstmal ein
raumschiff zum beispiel in einer wüste
landen sie könnten kontakt mit uns
aufnehmen und es hier so schön finden
dass wir uns wie wir in amerika immer
mehr gebiete abbringen und das natürlich
erst mal friedlich und instanzen später
erst zum konflikt kommt dann könnten wir
hier auf der erde die nötigen waffen
produziert haben und uns damit dann
angreifen und wie gesagt sie könnten am
anfang ganz friedlich sein und ist sogar
so meint aber was passiert später wir
können es nicht sagen ich finde wenn die
nase schon davon ausgeht dass wir in den
nächsten 20 jahren spätestens alien
finden dann sollten wir uns schon mal
gedanken
welche möglichen szenarien es gebe und
wie wir darauf reagieren ansonsten
gucken wir in der zukunft vielleicht mal
ziemlich dumm aus der wäsche ja wenn es
neuigkeiten bei der suche nach
außerirdischen gibt dann erfahrt ihr es
natürlich hier mit als erstes durch mehr
dafür hier ein abo aus augusta gäste
nicht den genau auf die glocke das
papier garantiert kein video hier geht
es zu weiteren videos zum thema
außerirdische sehr sehr spannend meine
empfehlung für heute und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt